first of all i want to say how excited i
am to see all eight episodes of this
series um what are you guys actually
most excited for fans to see
in the rings of power the extraordinary
thing about reading the books as a
youngster is i have my my imagination
fired by the lord of the rings and then
uh there's certain visual imagery out
there already from the movies etc but
this is a brand new world of the second
age and so
just the amount of the amount uh
the amount of new different
new worlds to get involved with and uh
how they're presented i'm just in in the
back of my head there's always like the
11 year old
kid who's never seen any of this before
ever never read anything and for the
first time they're going to be
introduced to tolkien's world
um that's that's what i'm most excited
about i'm excited for the dwarves
and the elves
the half feet
and these three guys numenoreans come on
i love that
[Laughter]
it's just all these beautiful worlds
coming together in such an amazing show
that is so special and dear to us that
we've
lived with for like three years and
it's we're bursting at the seams to for
the world to see it and
we've we've put so much care and love
into it that we hope you enjoy as well
but numenor in particular yeah i think
that's that's
we are the graces without a doubt of
course a hundred hundred percent um
what do you think fans of lord of the
rings would be surprised to learn about
the actual making of this series i'd say
in in the world of um in the world of
cgi they'd be very surprised to see how
much was actually made by
by hands
uh in our case the set of numenor is
absolutely phenomenal um
it took
months and months to build and and
landing on it uh as the actors in in the
costumes the amount the the skill of the
creators of this whole project
um
is
has been inspiring it's been wonderful
to be able to work with but just
yeah i think that's the surprise it's
it's it's been made it's real there'll
be elements of cgi of course but but
just the uh
the reality on the ground particularly
of numenor
will be uh will be a surprise i think
i also we didn't know what was happening
at the end of the season
because when we get the script we only
just get the script for like episodes so
we were like fans waiting for the for
each new episode to come in and we would
read it and then we'd call each other
and be like oh my god we're doing this
we're doing that and it was just
like a whirlwind of excitement
it's like children at christmas
i mean the level of detail i feel like
we've been hammering that a lot but yeah
i mean i just uh numenorm in particular
they built a city um there's like
alleyways there that probably don't even
make it on camera that are like amazing
um
there's this one
that has elvish that's been like
graffitied over with with numenorean
which if you know the lore is like a
beautiful little detail um but it's like
it's in this tiny corner that i found
one day that i don't i don't even know
if they're gonna shoot it but it's it's
awesome
how would you guys actually describe
like the scale and scope of the series
because it seems to me like this is
going to be immense it is
everything is bigger
everything is
uh just amped up and pushed to the
extreme uh of of what can be done and
achieved uh by tv i think they're
creating a new form of tvs like epic
tv where every single episode is like a
film it's digestible in a way that
sometimes
like longer style films aren't so
um it's more accessible in a way yeah
in terms of like crew and extras i know
for me like i had i had never been on
something with so many people just
showing up for work on the same day in
the same location
and in terms of scale and scope i mean
the scale and scope tolkien's
imagination is is unfathomable and uh
you know there's a limit to how much you
can do in terms of of his scope
but i think at this point in history
uh
and time and as as maxim was saying that
you you get a chance to write write a
bit more of a novel on celluloid and so
the amazon have given it this amount of
time space help love and resource is is
extraordinary because
the combination of
that amount of time
the elements that you can produce now
technically in terms of being able to
realize some of that imagination
of tolkien's is
makes makes the scope and scale enormous
but hopefully also
what we've done is trying to make that
domestic drama the sm the smallness of
the interpersonal relationships that how
these the scale of the events of of
middle earth and and the powers of the
gods and fate how they affect each
individual down at this really tiny
granular level has been our job as the
actor to try and to try and portray the
the truth of those moments between each
other last question for you guys without
spoilers uh which episode is your
favorite of the eight and why
i would say uh number two for me okay
it's an epic moment that connects all of
the worlds
and it's pretty it's pretty special and
i think when you watch it you'll
understand what i mean but episode two
for me i'd say uh six
five i like how each of you are giving a
different answer um i can't write listen
what about you
i'm gonna i'm gonna say episode one just
because it's gonna be you know
well anyway i'm listening i gotta i'm
already getting the signal to wrap no we
would be modest that we were being
modest we really love episode three
because when we first appear
simply the ego has to come through there
the golem inside us is saying three all
right i honestly cannot wait and uh i
really can't wait to talk to you guys
again in more detail about the actual
series
thank you so much for your time and wish
you guys nothing but the best